in his new book enough bill mckibben
warns of an impending tipping point
where technological advances outpace
human understanding next on book TV he
explores this moral and spiritual
boundary along the frontiers of genetic
research nanotechnology and robotics
it's an hour
I want to welcome Bill McKibben to
politics and prose this evening we were
just talking back in the office about he
has never been to politics and prose I
don't know how we could have dropped the
ball by not having him for the end of
nature that book came out about 15 years
ago it was the best seller I think
everybody who read the book was
tremendously excited about it excited
about the need to make change when I
picked up a volume that is done we got
here call them the writing life by Marie
arana who's the editor of The Washington
Post we're having her next month I saw
that she had included in her anthology
of people writing about the writing life
Bill McKibben and she said at the
beginning of this that thorough had said
it takes two people to speak truth one
to say it and another to hear it she
extends that somewhat into that it takes
two people to bring about change bring
about needful change one to write about
it to foment the ideas and others to
implement the the program into action
one of the things that has been sad for
Bill McKibben in the last 15 years was
which he writes about in here is seeing
after such a huge outburst of excitement
about the ideas in the end of nature
that still in the last 15 years there's
been little change that has come
practical change in his new book it's a
frightening scenario that he lays out
for us of weather that we're going to
have babies born
or babies manufactured of weather that
we're going to be able to genetically
design our human race if we be able to
clone it the weather that we can just
order babies with specific genetic
traits that we're looking for and that
they will be delivered to our doorstep
in nine months so he will tell you all
about this tonight it's an alarming
story and I think everybody needs to
read it thanks and here's be able to
give it
books have many uses it's a great
pleasure to be here tonight it's true
that I've never actually read here but
it's not true that I haven't been here
I've been here on many a trip to
Washington to come and buy books and
it's a this is a a great institution and
all of you are wise enough to know that
when you have a good independent
bookstore in your midst it's important
to patronize it a lot um it's a special
pleasure for me to be here tonight
because some of the some of the people
the best organizers the first organizers
the people who are giving birth to a new
movement around these questions of human
genetic engineering are here tonight
people from friends of the earth one of
our leading environmental organizations
and the first take a really outspoken
position on these questions and people
from a new group the Center for genetics
and society they have a table set up in
the front of the bookstore with
literature and things and and to sign up
for more information if you're
interested in it I'm just going to read
a little tiny bit tonight and then talk
for a while and then we'll have some
time yes for questions back and forth
and things um but I you if you'll
indulge me i'm going to read just a
little passage to start and i think i'm
reading it because i've been away from
home for a while and I'm missing my
family a lot uh Britain's Chief Rabbi
Jonathan Sacks was asked a few years ago
about the announcement that Italian
doctors were trying to clone humans if
there is a mystery at the heart of the
human condition he said it is other
pneus the other nuh sub man and woman
parent and child it is the space we make
for other pneus that makes love
something other than narcissism I
remember so well the feeling of walking
into the maternity ward with Sue and
walking out with Sue and Sophie where
there had been to that we're now somehow
three
each of us our own person but now
commanded to make a family a place where
we all could thrive she was so
mysterious that Sophie and in many ways
she still is there are times when like
every parent I see myself reflected in
her and times when I wonder whether
she's even related uh she's ours to
nurture and protect but she is who she
is that's the mystery and the glory of
any child mystery however is not one of
the words that thrills engineers they
try and deliver solid bridges unyielding
dams reliable cars we wouldn't want it
any other way the only question is
whether their product line should be
expanded to include children fifty years
ago almost to the day Watson and Crick
sounded the starting gun on the genetic
revolution with their description of the
double helix a great moment in our
intellectual history and since that time
enormous and fascinating progress has
been made in understanding the
underlying mechanisms of our biology and
more and more we're learning how to put
that understanding to good and and and
and and sometimes almost miraculous use
as we design better drugs able to deal
with a wide variety of disease as we
begin to be able to at least start with
gene therapy for for patients who are
afflicted with a range of disease as
we're able now to screen embryos to
prevent the most crippling defects but
we're also at this fifth decade of this
revolution near a place where this path
may begin to diverge and diverge in in
much more troubling directions for the
last ten years scientists in a variety
of labs in a variety of countries have
been able to
begin to take the embryos of many
different kinds of animals and alter
their DNA add or subtract portions of it
in an effort to produce particular
traits in the resulting animal a
scientist would call this germline
genetic engineering germline meaning
employees the germ cells a layman would
call it the creation of designer babies
we have animals that are bigger than
they would otherwise be much bigger and
animals that are smaller we have mice
that are smarter as we measure such
things in mice we have animals whose a
makeup and emotional behavior have been
emotional makeup and social behavior
have been profoundly changed through the
alteration of DNA all of which is a
reflection of the fact that even though
for many people it's an ideologically
uncomfortable idea jeans play an
enormous role in a number of ways we
know from a wide variety of studies of
twins for instance that an awful lot of
the characteristics that we think of as
part of ourselves are linked to one
degree or another by heredity there are
now scientists who are eager to extend
that same kind of work that same kind of
engineering work that has been done on
animals into the realm of human beings
they aren't obscure or fringe scientists
uh people like James Watson himself has
said as recently as this winter how
important it is to do this germline
genetic engineering as soon as possible
in order to ensure that there are no
more stupid people um in order to deal
with social problems like shyness um in
order to improve the physical appearance
of human beings who wants an ugly baby
was how he put it um um there are plenty
of others thinking along the same lines
uh uh uh the chief of gene structure at
the nash
Cancer Institute's biochemistry
laboratory wrote a fascinating essay in
which he looked the little ways into the
future and not very far he said and
imagined parents arriving at a clinic in
order to tweak the emotional makeup of
their child able to choose on a spectrum
that ran and and this is really semi
plausible because we're beginning to
understand which genes regulate
production of chemicals in the brain
like dopamine and serotonin and things
able to choose a but on a spectrum that
ran from mother Teresa to you know jack
welch sort of cutthroat CEO um um um all
these things are at the very least
plausible and all these things fit
neatly or too neatly into our consumer
model of how we behave um that we buy
things that we want and all of them seem
at least at some level superficially
attractive there's not a parent in here
who doesn't wish for their child every
good thing so the first question for me
was why did this sort of talk leave me
feeling so queasy and not just me i have
now confident having traveled around the
country talking about these questions
that it leaves an enormous number of
people feeling queasy across religious
lines across political lines across
educational lines across socio-economic
lines where is that queasiness come from
some of it comes from extremely
pragmatic considerations things that
should be obvious to anyone who spends
any time looking at the world in which
we live 40 million Americans have no
access at all really to medical care we
live in a world where more than a
million people a year die of malaria
largely because we can't even get it
selves together to provide the dollar it
would take to buy them bed nets to
mosquitoes from biting them in that kind
of world this sort of technology would
clearly be reserved for people of means
and power and it would serve the effect
of rewriting into our very biology those
divisions and wealth and power that
should already trouble us to probably a
greater extent than they seem to UM it's
not opponents of this work so much you
were saying this it's the very people
who are proposing to do it who recognize
this inevitable outcome fascinating a
piece of writing by a Princeton
geneticist named Lee silver an essay
called remaking eden forecast his vision
of the future where in in in his words
we will soon divided into what he called
the gin rich and the naturals and by his
calculation in the foreseeable future
these two this divergence will proceed
to the point where these two groups pc8
where they're no longer able to
interbreed where they become different
things that alone should it seems to me
give one significant pause before
embarking on a technology like this this
isn't a new technology like the
telephone or the television or the car
or something that'll be difficult to
assimilate but which you know at some
level or another we'll figure out how to
deal with even if it comes at some cost
this is a quantum leap into a very
different world it takes us across a
threshold that we can barely imagine and
on the other side of that threshold I'm
convinced the thing that makes me queasy
'used on the other side of that
threshold being a human being will mean
something very different and something
diminished from what it means now human
identity and human meaning I've come to
think are more fragile and more
vulnerable than we usually imagine which
is to say
I can argue only by analogy here because
we haven't done this and there's no one
who can come back from the other side
and tell us what it feels like but if
you imagine if you remember a few years
ago when prozac appeared on the scene
clearly a great blessing to a great many
people clearly also almost from the
moment of its inception a source of a
kind of existential unsettling pneus you
will recall it wasn't very many months
before the most important popular book
in America dealt with this question of
who who am I and who is the drug and how
do I tell what does that mean well now
imagine as these engineers do a an
alteration a hundred times more profound
and powerful than that able to choose
one's emotional makeup in the most
comprehensive way imagine inserting it
in a child in an embryo who grows into a
child who grows into a human into an
adult and who has never able to for a
second escape that particular flood of
whatever proteins whatever chemicals
have been designated for them um who
never knows at some level whether
they're happy or this you know pfizer
product in their genes or whoever is
going to end up making it is is is happy
what that means um for me the more
thought about it the more this sense of
of of what it would mean to make
products out of people became for me the
most deeply and profoundly unsettling
part of of this consideration
given that we're politics and prose I'm
going to talk for just a minute about
the politics in a way of this issue
which is something I don't always do it
on our greens but i think it's it's
fascinating and important it's a very
open and interesting question as to
whether we could even if we wanted to
stop this kind of work you know it may
be that we were sort of either you know
doomed or destined to carry forward
every technological project we can
imagine to its logical conclusion um in
some ways that's a question about human
nature whether that striving a part of
us the sort of grasping part of us the
more is better part of us is the sum
total of our nature or not um it's
certainly the part that we've developed
most powerfully in a sort of consumer
America for the last 50 years but it
clearly is a part of us I think however
that there's another part of us as well
a deeper part of our human nature if you
asked one of the questions that
inevitably arises in a in a in a debate
as profound as this one is sort of
questions about what humans are and what
they are like you sort of have to deal
with questions that abstract ephemeral
and usually avoided in order to really
get a handle on these things and if you
asked me if you ask me even I'll ask
myself uh what is it that makes us
different I think the answer really is
that we're the creature that can decide
not to do something that we're capable
of doing that we have a capacity for
self restraint um in some ways this is
the once one strips away ritual and
Creed and dogma and superstition this is
the core of the religious idea that goes
back at least as far as the Buddha and
been to our present day um usually it's
been a sort of individual and almost
aesthetic virtue the process of
maturation of putting something else at
the center but now it needs in the face
of this kind of dilemma to become a
civic societal even civilizational
virtue if that happens if that process
even begins it'll have to play itself
out politically this needs to become
this issue needs desperately to become
part of our vigorous democratic debate
it can't be left to scientists alone to
figure out it's not fair to scientists
to charge them with that anymore than it
would be fair to say to the people who
had just built the atomic bomb okay now
go tell us you know where we should drop
it it calls for a different kind and a
much wider range of human participation
in order to make this case what's most
interesting politically in this country
I think is that this issue doesn't fall
along left right lines very easily it
doesn't fit within our normal political
categories all that simply arm instead
and I'm indebted to rich Hayes for of
the Center for genetics and society for
for some of this analysis instead it
falls much more easily along a sort of
division between people who have a
strong libertarian bent and people who
think about the larger community as part
of their frame of reference and there
are libertarians and and communitarians
scattered across our traditional
political spectrum left to right all
over the place people who are fancy
themselves deeply libertarian of whom
I'm not one um tend to believe that
infringement upon the rights of parents
to pursue this kind of technology with
their offspring would be a grave
infringement
um one of the reasons I think that we
will win this argument in the end that
this movement will be successful as it
has been successful across Europe in
outlying germline genetic engineering in
outlying outline designer babies is
because even among libertarians that
argument seems to me extremely weak and
extremely unlikely to hold up because
what are you basically talking about
here in political terms you're talking
about two people parents going into a
clinic someplace and deciding on a long
list of items exactly how that what
their child what another human being
will be like their entire lives and
indeed since these genes will pass on
for many generations there after picking
the precise mix of different proteins
that will be washing out of every cell
in their body for their entire lives
there's never been a more paternalistic
or maternal istic idea than that you
know and and the notion that uh you know
people who get outraged about like
government control an airline government
regulation of airlines would find it
completely permissible that one human
being should be allowed to design
another human being um strikes me as
politically absurd in fact an awful lot
of this superficially appealing
technology becomes politically and
humanely absurd the more you think about
it the more you understand what it would
mean to take people and make them into
products let me end with just this small
image
you and your partner decide that you
want a child so you go to the clinic and
you have credit enough in your visa card
to get the best possible upgrade that's
available at the moment some of the
genetic engineers talk about being able
to add 20 30 IQ points at some point in
the future things like that you go back
five years later for your second child
okay by this time of course technology
being technology has moved on and
there's a better upgrade available for
this next one you know a whole anything
that would turn your first child into
Windows 95 should on its face be enough
to convince any loving parent and any
concerned citizen I think that this is a
track we don't want to go down we don't
need to go down it in order to deal with
the wide range of genetic disease that
still troubles us and if we do go down
it we buy into a world that we can only
dimly imagine but that dim imagination
we can draw on should be enough to
persuade us that it's a world full of
shadows there I end thank you very much
we have questions or or abuse or
anything I think you're supposed to go
to the microphone there and the uh thank
you um I was just a couple thoughts I
have while you're talking one was Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein and besides I me
my feeling is besides you know your sir
patient of the Creator and this whole
issue is the idea in that book I'm
reading a long time but what that would
do between is you're talking about the
parent-child relationship where you
create something and then there's
abandonment and I was sort of you had
any thoughts about that absolutely i
mean this uh um you know if it works the
way that it's you know fondest
proponents imagine it'll create a
generation gap in a way that that we've
never experienced before you know um the
sort of cry that I already hear from my
ten-year-old you know dad you just don't
understand will become a sort of literal
you know the creation of superior or
whatever transcendent human beings um
it's also i'm glad that you brought up
frankenstein because it forget
frankenstein for a minute and in the ERV
would consider all its descendants in
the world of science fiction you know I
hadn't read much science fiction before
I in a long time before I went to work
on this book and then I read some in the
course of doing it it was not what I
remembered it was not the you know buck
rogers in space you know a happy cowboys
in the galaxy kind of stuff I would
wager that it is the single darkest and
most dystopian aisle in this bookshelf
is the one devoted to science fiction
movies like The Matrix in gattaca are
very representative
the genre and there's a reason for that
these are the only people who have had
to sit down and take the scale of these
coming technologies and juxtapose them
with the scale of actual human beings of
these characters they're trying to
create write about and when they do that
thought experiment which is what a novel
really is um they're almost universally
unable to come out with the happy ending
from it the scale of one is too great it
overwhelms the scale of the other which
is one of the reasons that this book is
called enough partly it's because you
know you can say it in a lot of
different voices you can say enough
already you know this is too much it's
freaking me out I don't you know and
that that's a legitimate response to
some of this stuff but you can also say
enough you know we're at a pretty good
place 500 years into the Scientific
Revolution we live long lives easy lives
for the most part in this part of the
world comfortable lives it's pretty
difficult to come up with a reason why
it's so all important that we take this
kind of leap across into some unknown
world so that's a very good point is
there any historical example of us as a
species exercising the kind of restraint
you're talking about and choosing not to
do something we're capable of this is a
very good question and a very important
one um in some ways it's the central
question of the last third of this book
there have been two my mind three of
these thresholds in our sort of living
memory okay the first was the invention
of atomic weapons and with them the
understanding that in a instant one
could obliterate everything around us
have we figured out restraint they're
not completely obviously I mean we're
still dealing hard with this question uh
but but we clearly had to quickly start
re-evaluating what kind of force and
level of violence and things made sense
and perhaps it's some tiny tribute that
Nagasaki was the last of these things so
far that we've drawn the second of these
threshold issues I think was the sort of
environmental moment in general the
environmental crisis in general and most
particularly the the realization that
there were now enough of us to begin
changing the temperature of the planet
in fundamental ways that we were now
going to be altering everything that
happened on the surface again our
restraint has been in this country close
to non-existent on so far but in other
parts of the world there's at least the
beginning of some real action and
furthermore if one was looking hoping I
should say by Nature cockeyed optimism
is not my forte I mean I wrote a book
called the end of nature um you know but
if one were looking for a kind of
optimistic here's what I would say if
we'd been here 30 years ago and someone
had asked say Brent blackwelder ahead of
friends of the earth what's the single
most intractable problem that we face
environmentally he might well have said
it's the endless spiral of human
population that just seems to be going
up and up forever and ever with no end
in sight human beings went to work on
that issue began with environmentalists
and development people been in this
country at first but then very quickly
in the developing
world and they very quickly figured out
some important and powerful techniques
by far the most important of which
involved the education and empowerment
of women okay as a result human
fertility has dropped in ways that
people could would never have guessed
the average woman 30 years ago had six
children the average woman in this world
now has fewer than three and the number
is falling fast consciously and
unconsciously we came up against a limit
of some kind I could see one coming and
began to restrain ourselves now we may
have waited a little too long to start
and you know because of demographic
momentum we're going to go from six
billion of us now to nine billion of us
or so before it tops out still at all
it's a kind of moving example of humans
being able to restrain themselves you
know in a realm that you might have said
would be sort of hardwired in a
Darwinian way it would be extremely
difficult this set of technologies will
be harder still to restrain because they
appear in seductive guys you know and so
I'm I I'm by no means I'm sure that this
question will come out the right way but
I am sure that there are a lot of people
around this country I now I know this
from the last few weeks of traveling
around who understand at some intuitive
level at some gut visceral level uh that
there's something very wrong in these uh
plans and futures and who may well be
able to figure out the ways necessary to
help us exercise that restraint yes I
have a question and that is of have you
or other futurists thought of the
possible scenario where they educated
and the wealthy would take advantage of
these technologies to enhance
their superior position in society also
understanding at the same time that they
did those who are so gifted would be
wasting a lot of times sweeping the
floor and doing the dishes and so that
would present an economic incentives to
another of class of people that they
would be genetically engineered to do
hard physical labor to be patient two of
you know the scenario these are the kind
of these are the kind of you know the
sort of social outcomes that that we
should we know hopefully will avoid ever
even having to find out if we're that uh
if we're that kind of people that would
allow that something like that to happen
um you know given human history it's
certainly not a crazy to imagine such
scenarios but I think the major question
here is not sort of state eugenics and
you know jack boots on the stairs and
master races and and and sub braces and
things like that it's the deep consumer
appeal of it that's how this will happen
as a sort of product of market forces if
it happens and it makes you know it
reminds me anyway that there are certain
things that should be beyond market
forces and this is one of them that it
is much too intimate a thing to leave to
the to the good or bad winds of the
marketplace to decide
near the minor further to Barbara's
comment just although I didn't get a
chance to do anything but scan it I
think there was a review in today's post
about the book on gated communities um
and the same is something along the
lines of your book which is that this
competitive desire to have people who
have some ability to separate themselves
from the not so fortunate and I guess
this is the ultimate ability to pay for
it and do it but then the question is
what happens to the less fortunate
they're still going to exist and if you
can't employ them in the way that
Barbara is suggesting that you have to
create ever more gated communities to
protect yourself from a growing
population of people who may be less
able but who pose a threat then to to
those folks they observe as being better
off the political scientist Francis
Fukuyama has written tellingly on this
set of questions sort of analyzing the
basic threat not threat I mean the the
complete assault on democracy that would
be represented by having to you know if
I having biologically different uh
strains of people you know the notion
that we were all created equal would
become you know literally wouldn't be
true some of us would be created in a
completely different way um and and as I
say that alone should be enough to make
us wave off this set of technologies but
I'm not sure it will be that's why we
have to understand that even for the
people who will be the theoretical
beneficiaries of this kind of work that
cost in personhood in meaning in
identity I I mean even if you were
parents have the cash to make you a
superior robot you know a superior
programmed individual that's still what
you are you know um and and we need
since its people with wealth and power
that make these kind of decisions in our
society they need to understand that
life inside this biological gated
community is going to be inhuman as well
I think they want you to go around yes
yeah
so you've raised a lot of philosophical
objections to the technology which I
think are important but I think there's
a big practical objection which you
might have u prime mention the book
haven't read it which is that even if
you put aside the philosophical
objections it's not clear to me that a
society made of IQ 150 liters where
everyone is a leader known as a follower
can function and that that's a practical
consideration on a philosophical one and
the other question I have so that's
actually in a way a tactical question if
we have a movement against this
technology and what order should these
objections be brought up and the other
tactical question I had was whether
people ever considered baiting these
scientists because I've seen likely
silver stuff in my alumni magazine and
what strikes me is that the guy's a
loser like he is not able though he's
not able to cure malaria so he wants to
pursue assigned a question which to me
is not really scientifically interesting
to the extent it's scientifically
interesting they could do this in
animals you know you might want to breed
a new animal or something instead he
wants to anoint himself the kind of some
kind of high priest and get all sorts of
attention and so well avoiding the ad
hominem for the moment I will say only
this um um in fact people were that many
people are fascinating and interesting
and and and and much to their credit
they've spoken extremely frankly about
their vision of the world and what it
would entail but one of the things that
they say many of the proponents of this
sort of technology one of the things
they say over and over is that there's
nothing special about human beings at
all um that there's no reason to fear
sort of loss of human meaning because it
doesn't exist that we're sort of meat
machines at some level already anyhow um
and and hence these sort of questions
don't interest them and that's why it's
really important to try and I think to
try and figure out what if anything is
distinctive about human beings and why
I think this capacity for restraint in
some way is one of the key both tactical
but also philosophical parts of this
debate as for the question about
everybody having 150 IQ I mean you've
quickly isolated another one of the the
logical problems with this I mean if
your idea is you're going to do this for
your kid will get into Harvard you know
rest assured that everybody else in
Chevy Chase will be doing it you know at
the same week you know and so you know
you're no closer to her than you were
when you began something hi I was
wondering if you could uh more fully
described the the economics behind the
rule i guess genetic research like um
does most of the money that comes like
obviously these scientists they have to
be getting grants or research money does
it come from the government does it come
from like psycho Foundation has come
from large corporations like where
exactly I mean are the scientists
getting the resources to do too well
there's a number of different sources
and it depends on sort of where the work
is and what stage it's at and things um
there's a lot of basic research going on
and some of this fall's very much into
that category and it's funded from the
usual variety of sources there are a
number of foundations we're very
interested in promoting the sort of idea
of this kind of work and sponsoring
exhibits and panels and Spears and
things books in order to sort of lay the
foundation for it and there's in the
sort of biotechnology industry at large
a lot of venture capital sloshing around
because it doesn't you know you don't
have to be an enormous you know savant
to realize that there are big payoffs
potentially in many of these areas and
it's not as if much of it now is sort of
invested with the idea of doing any one
of these particular things you know but
it's there's all sorts of work going on
at all kinds of different levels and
amazing and troubling discoveries
happening in an almost weekly basis I
don't know if people saw the paper last
week uh
completely fascinating and I think
fairly scary a piece of research that
was published in either science or
nature this week people were able to
take adult stem cells a University of
Pennsylvania group and uh and we have
them convert into eggs and then those
eggs were able to convert into what
appear to be embryos pretty much on
their own of parthenogenesis innate and
perhaps potentially a one-step among
many in precisely the direction I'm
describing okay thank you thank you
do you see this problem is one that can
be addressed best individually
politically socially or religiously well
yeah I mean I suppose the correct answer
is all you know just D all of the above
but um let me say that before it can be
effectively politically addressed at
some level people need to understand it
enough you know have asked me enough
sort of beginning discussion and
understanding that people feel competent
in order to sort of take part in that
debate one of the problems is that when
people hear about genetics it seems
impossibly complicated something that
they couldn't hope to understand that's
not true uh if you want to go do genetic
engineering you'd be best advised to
pursue a PhD in biology and get very
good at this um but if you want to
understand it and debate it and be able
to have a role in its you know uh
determining what makes sense to do with
it that's not at all necessary it would
help to excuse alright put a little plug
and say read a book you know on the
subject um um um um but that's where
it's going to grow out of and then as
the debate is joined all the forces that
you mentioned will be important I um
yeah this kind of follows up on some of
the other questions it I know through
reading some of these scientists who are
pushing this technology one of the
arguments that they use is it's
inevitable you know that inevitability
argument that we always get with just
about anything that scientists serve up
to society you know there's just no way
to stop it and I think it's one of the
things that gives me hope is that it
seems that in the last 20 years or so we
have started to question some of the new
scientific developments that have come
down the pike for instance the genetic
engineering of plants is starting to be
subjected to societal not just
scientific criteria
so I would ask you to address that and
then also just one other thing is that
when James Watson says that no one wants
stupid people I would suggest that he's
he displays moral stupidity and that we
should you know call some of these
scientists you know on on that point
there are times when one is a move to
reflect on the differences between
intelligence and wisdom people sometimes
um on the question of inevitability it's
a very important question and it's you
know used as a kind of um bludgeon you
know to defeat you can't fight city hall
we're gonna do whatever words possible
to do so on and so forth and they're
certainly you know it's not a ignorant
idea I mean we do do most of the things
that we figured out how to do however
your example of genetic modification of
plants is a very interesting one and it
cuts a number of ways when I was writing
the end of nature it was mostly about
climate change but since it was really
about the relationship between human
beings and natural world I devoted a few
pages to what then seemed in 1989 the
very nascent science of crop
bioengineering there was about a half
acre of strawberries planted in the bay
area that had been that had a flounder
gene inserted to protect against frost
and I was it four years later half the
corn and soy in this country was
genetically modified I mean these sort
of things can happen very quickly but
then as you point out this out of almost
nowhere this movement arose in Europe of
people saying no they didn't want this
and so far it's been a remarkably
effective movement it's it's it hasn't
stopped genetically modified foods in
their tracks but it has remarkably
slowed their growth and reminded us of
the usefulness of that kind of
democratic debate and in this case you
know we're so far still ahead of the
game I mean this hasn't happened yet so
you know
it's a little early to call it
inevitable I mean the genie is you know
uh wiggling her shoulders trying to get
out of the bottle but she's still there
for the moment you know we've one more
we're beginning to run a little short on
time so I'm going to ask the three
people who and who are in line if you
would ask your question and then we'll
see how Bill McKibben can find a way to
answer all three to us this is like a
test this is I'm JD Hanson worked for
the United Methodist Church on these
issues of biotechnology as we've gone
around the the church and had people
done hearings and done things the the
question that seems to come up is not
the frank inside the Frankenstein side
of it but my child has juvenile diabetes
my child has cystic fibrosis my father
my father actually has Parkinson's and
and I bit as my mother has Alzheimer's
the the way the argument is sometimes
posed to me is how can you be against
anything that might possibly cure these
diseases my my guess is that the
question used to be why does God allow
suffering the question now is why in the
world are you getting in the way of
science eliminating suffering I'm going
to answer this one before it because
otherwise i'll forget it don't forget it
but i want it's important and vitally
important and needs to be addressed the
good news is that though the lines are
not perfect they're reasonably bright
and one can deal with
human disease in existing people without
doing this kind of germline genetic
engineering in a wide variety of ways as
we get much better at doing a you know
developing therapies new drugs and
things as we begin to do what's called
somatic gene therapy on existing
individuals who have problems we can in
essence inject them with healthy genetic
material in the hopes that that will
begin to express its or overwhelm the
other of DNA and produce the necessary
proteins and some of that work is
showing promise and in the case in the
sort of ultimate case of people who are
at grave risk of a child with cystic
fibrosis or some other strong
genetically linked disease we are now
able to do and do do on a fairly large
scale what's called embryo screening or
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis any
of this work involves going into a
clinic and having an embryo out on a
table whether you do germline genetic
engineering or anything else if you're
going to do that anyway we now are able
to take naturally produced embryos from
the sperm and the egg of a couple and
look at those and figure out which ones
carry the trait that you are at risk for
and which don't and implant the healthy
ones that technology can be abused as
well as we get more sophisticated will
be able to also look at those embryos
and figure out a number of other things
gender you know which ones are likely to
be tall or whatever else but so far
we've managed to limit that work pretty
much to these really deleterious a set
of genetic diseases and it's the classic
example of how with a little wisdom and
a little humility we can take this kind
of knowledge of the last 50 years and
put it to good use without crossing into
this shadow land
actually my question was just I can
probably follow up on what he had which
is really I wanted to address the issue
that that if I think there's an ethical
issue if you do have a treatment that
will work through germline manipulation
but not through somatic cell
manipulation there's an ethical issue
and you saying well I can't make the
germline modification but I can't help
you once once the child is born or comes
down with the condition so I think there
are issues that you in making that
decision not to do that I think there
are ethical issues which are significant
as saying that that you know we're not
going to do something happily because
with this for instance this embryo
screening technology if there's a
condition for which one can detect one
can select against and that would be so
anything that you might possibly be able
to do in terms of fighting you know
disease through germline genetic
engineering through DNA alteration in to
ward off these particular genetic
diseases you'd be able to do without
taking that step with this much simpler
and already in use set of technologies I
have a comment it seems to me given how
you've described the current state of
affairs in this whole area of issues
it's very worthwhile to look back to the
whole period when eugenics was a popular
thing not just in the Third Reich but in
this country to in the 20s and 30s when
I was a kid in school back in the 1930s
we were studying the Jukes and the
cowlick acts who were supposed to be
badly developed people who in principle
should be eliminated through things like
sterilization now the this this gives
ground grounds for both optimism and
pessimism pessimism because the best and
the brightest in our society were very
often in that period a strong apologists
for this whole approach
which was very closely related to the
racism of the Third Reich go be no the
grounds for optimism is that we have
since abandoned that and as you say
Europe more than here but the fact that
at a certain period our society and
European society was prepared to accept
these that approach and has since
abandoned it is it seems grounds for
optimism I agree and I think that it's
one way of saying that is that well in
certain ways these technologies seem
incredibly shiny and new and
forward-looking there's another sense in
which they're deeply retrograde and and
appeal to a set of fantasies that we
should have left behind you know there
are problems in this world the day when
we decide we're not going to come up
with some technological fix for those
problems is probably the day when will
actually get around to addressing them
in the ways that we know they actually
need to be addressed and and that's one
of the very good reasons that it
probably really is time to say enough
with certain of these measures thank you
Bill McKibben's books include the end of
nature the age of missing information
and long distance a year of living
strenuously his latest enough is
published by henry holt and company on
the web at henry holt calm